decided that online dating was too hard  so i had men from the internet interview  with my parents before they can meet  with me you know what you're thinking  who would make a guy that she doesn't  even know interview with her parents  before they can meet her me that's who i  sent this intro message you can pause if  you want to read it if you're interested  shoot me a message he says what if i  fall for your mom though instead of you  this guy said very interested i'm great  with parents i'll charm her socks off  this guy said what [ __ ] it i'm in sounds  fun is she as cute as you is she single  my mom took all the work out of online  dating she would just send me a text  give me the pros and cons of each guy